did President Trump collude with Ukraine
did Joe Biden collude with Ukraine who's
colluding with Russia somebody must be
colluding with Russia we will examine
the fallout from president Trump's phone
call with Ukrainian leader
volodia Mir of zalenski and what it
means for the White House and more
importantly what it means for the Biden
campaign then Sarah Silverman gets woke
on canceled culture more border wall
gets built
Candace Owens kills it in congressional
testimony and the left encourages a
mentally ill child to drop out of school
to help them sell socialism all that and
more i'm michael knowles and this is the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
collusion slots of collusion collusion
all around President Trump
Kalu dijo all kinds of collusion we will
examine exactly what happened because
there's a lot of confusion on this story
collusion and confusion what happened
President Trump had a phone call with
ukrainian leader
Volodymyr zalenski in which he allegedly
asked him multiple times to investigate
potential collusion by Joe Biden when
Joe Biden was vice president and Joe
Biden's son hunter Biden not the one who
died but the one who's still alive and
the Ukrainian government we'll get to
the actual corruption allegations in a
second just what happened on the phone
call the Ukrainian foreign minister
vadym priest Aiko says Trump did not put
any pressure on the Ukrainian president
during the call a so-called
whistleblower in the intelligence
community filed a complaint with the
Acting Director of National Intelligence
Joseph Maguire about the Quall but he's
not actually a whistleblower
he's a leaker because he doesn't have
any direct knowledge of the phone call
itself that's even according to CNN
Biden is making a big issue about the
call Congress is already calling for
impeachment okay that is just setting
this stage what is the big takeaway from
all of this we'll get to that in a
second but first safety is very very
important it's important internationally
it's important as a matter of national
security and it's important for you
rings mission is to make neighborhoods
safer you probably already know about
their smart video doorbell and cameras
that protect millions of people
everywhere you probably know about them
because I talk about them all the time
ring helps you stay connected to your
home anywhere in the world so if there's
a package delivery or if there's a
surprise visitor you will get an alert
you will be able to see here and speak
to them all from your phone this is
actually what I really like about it the
most because it does help me feel safe
and secure
obviously I I hit the road a lot sweet
little lease is a pretty good shot but I
don't want to just rely on that so it
does make me feel safe but it also makes
me feel really cool because it's like
the Jetsons you know it's like living in
the future where you can be you can
effectively be in your home even if
you're at the office even if you're on a
beach somewhere that's because of the HD
video and too
audio features on ring devices so this
helped my producer Jonathan hey you know
a few months ago some wackos tried to
knock on his door in the middle of the
night and he just spoke to them from his
bed and they scattered away other
friends who I gave ring to as a
housewarming gift they were really
nervous about who was going around their
home at night they found out it was a
possum if by the way a burglar even
steals your ring device that's uploaded
to the cloud so you get to see him
anyway as a listener you have a special
offer and a ring starter kit available
right now with a video doorbell and
motion activated floodlight camera the
starter kit has everything you need to
start building a ring of security around
your home go to ring.com Sailaja Knolls
cana wles that's ring.com slash Knolls
okay are you confused about this ukraine
call i am confused about this ukraine
call but i think i've sorted it out the
big takeaway here the 30,000 foot view
is that democrats and the left or
totally miss playing their hand here
okay that's the political takeaway and
and this is not surprising because they
totally miss played their hand on
russian collusion for three years they
totally miss played their hand on stormy
Daniels campaign finance for three years
they totally miss played their hand on
Brett Cavanaugh's allegations you know
that he was a super duper gang rapist or
something they totally miss played their
hand okay they have very little in the
way of facts that's the common thread
here they have very little on facts and
Cavanaugh and stormy Daniels and on
Russian collusion on its steel dossier
they have very little in the way of
facts here about this phone call okay
what they have a lot of is innuendo so
they could they could actually use all
of this to raise questions even when we
found out that they were hoaxes the
Russia hoax the Cavanaugh hoax the
campaign finance I guess is still
unresolved but it's going nowhere they
could use that innuendo to raise
questions is Brett Kavanaugh fit to be
on the Supreme Court they don't you
don't want to pursue it too much because
the more you dig into the facts the more
you realize Cavanaugh is totally
innocent did Donald Trump collude with
Russia is he a traitor to his country as
he corrupt is he crooked you don't want
to dig into it too
because you dig into it with a two-year
Muller investigation you find out he's
totally exonerated on conspiracy or
collusion with Russia but if you just
raise the questions and you play a
little soft and you played a little
subtle it actually could have worked to
their political benefit that's what
could have happened here with this this
phone call with Ukraine if they didn't
call for impeachment they didn't call
for investigations if they just said
here's more evidence that Trump is
corrupt he's willing to abuse his power
and we're not going to impeach him for
it but this is if they just used it to
paint a picture it could work possibly
to their political benefit but they
can't do it they can't underplay it
instead every single time they have to
overplay it they have to say Trump
didn't just have connections to people
connected to Russia he's working for
Moscow and you say that's obviously not
true we know that that isn't true Brett
Kavanaugh didn't just party when he was
in high school in college he is a rapist
we you can check these things we that
isn't true
Donald Trump didn't simply try to twist
the Ukrainian president's arm to get him
to look into a political rival he's
colluding he's breaking the law he's
abusing his power and now you're gonna
do investigations and you're gonna find
out more and more about what Trump is
asking about which doesn't raise
questions really about Trump it raises
questions about Biden which the
Democrats if they had two brain cells in
their head would want to avoid because
Biden is currently their best chance at
beating Trump and their torpedo in his
campaign what are the details here the
details are so bizarre it will leave you
scratching your head
the details are looks so bad for the
Biden's that you you can't help but
wonder why on earth would you call
attention to this the Biden campaign or
Democrats in general hear the details I
guess the main thing you got to know is
that Joe Biden's son hunter is a
complete degenerate now we're not
talking about Joe Biden's son Beau who
died of brain cancer beau was sort of
the upright Biden's son he was Attorney
General of Delaware he looked like he
had the political future ahead of them
and he tragically died a few years ago
we're talking about hunter Biden who is
a derelict degenerate he was discharged
from the Navy one
after receiving his commission why
because they found he tested positive
for doing a bunch of coke his wife left
him for squandering money on drugs and
hookers you can read that in the court
documents in 2016 hunter decided to
start sleeping with his dead brother's
widow after spending a week buying crack
in downtown LA someone pulled a gun on
him while he was buying crack in
downtown LA he kept going back there
all of this attested to all of this has
been well reported on the romance didn't
last very long with his late brother's
widow and he dumped his brother's widow
pretty soon thereafter now on that same
trip to LA where he was buying crack and
getting guns pulled on him he got into a
fight with somebody at a Hollywood Club
a man named baby down I assume that's
not his Christian name I assume that's a
nickname baby down drops hunter off at a
Hertz rental car office hunter takes the
rental car from Hertz drives it to
Arizona the cops catch up with him after
the Hertz staffers call the cops when
Hunter Biden leaves the office the cops
find a crack pipe a bag with a white
powdery substance a secret service
business card hunter biden's license and
a badge from his brother as time as
Attorney General of Delaware they find
all of that on the car what happens to
hunter Biden the cops declined to press
charges they just didn't have enough
evidence it's what they said there's a
hallmark of Hunter Biden's life is again
and again and again he gets off because
his father is a prominent politician
that's just a little background on this
guy now what does that mean for the
dealings in Ukraine it actually tells us
a lot about the dealings in Ukraine so
what happened in Ukraine is a few years
ago Ukraine's top prosecutor was looking
into a money-laundering scheme by a
company called Purisima Holdings this is
a classic crony company and Oleg ARCIC
type company in Ukraine hunter Biden for
some reason was on the board of burries
Mahal Deng's and being paid $50,000 a
month it's a lot of money $600,000 a
year what was he being paid all that
money for was he being paid all that
money for his expertise on Ukrainian
energy the guy who was getting pinched
for buying crack and down
town la sleeping with his brother's wife
and his own wife leaves him because he
squanders his money on drugs and hookers
that guy that's the guy who has such
expertise specifically in Ukrainian
energy that they pay him six hundred
thousand dollars a year for his
expertise yeah maybe it's that or maybe
it's that he was peddling his father's
influence because his father was the top
diplomat at the time right as far as
fathers the vice president and he's
handling a lot of negotiations with
Ukraine so what happens then the
prosecutor is looking into hunter
Biden's shady business dealings in
Ukraine Vice President Biden then
insisted that the prosecutor be removed
from office and he said if the
prosecutor wasn't removed from office he
would withhold 1 billion dollars in
Ukraine aid now that Ukraine pushed back
on this and they said you don't have the
power to do that and Joe Biden said I'll
call Barak right now and and show you
that we're gonna keep that aid unless
you fire the prosecutor who's looking
into my son does all that sound like a
conspiracy theory I know it does it does
sound like a conspiracy theory
fortunately you don't need to take my
word for it Joe Biden actually bragged
about doing this exact thing at the
Council on Foreign Relations here is I
went over I guess the 12th 13th time to
Kiev and and I was going supposed to
announce that there was another billion
dollar loan guarantee and I had gotten a
commitment from poroshenko and from
Yatsenyuk that they would take action
against the state prosecutor and they
didn't so they said that if they were
walking out to press kind of said nice
and I'm not gonna or when we're not
going to give you the billion dollars
they said you have no authority you're
not the president the president said I
said call him
I said I'm telling you're not getting a
billion dollars I said you're not
getting a billion I'm gonna be leaving
here I think it was about six hours I
looked I said I'm leaving in six hours
and the prosecutors not fired you're not
getting the money Oh son of a put in
place someone who was solid okay now how
are they spinning this the Biden
campaign is spinning this and saying he
didn't like the prosecutor because the
prosecutor wasn't doing enough to root
out corruption that's a pretty pretty
detailed interest you're taking that's a
pretty intense interest you're taking in
a prosecutor in a foreign country over
some local corruption or something isn't
it
that doesn't seem to add up a whole lot
maybe that interest is is more easily
explained because the prosecutor was
looking into your own son's corruption
which could reflect pretty badly on you
why would why would Biden brag about
this at the Council on Foreign Relations
makes perfect sense politically you got
to get out ahead of the story you've got
to define the story as you want it's not
very credible the way that he's defining
it but at least he's got his story out
there before this breaks even left-wing
media outlets aren't buying this we'll
get to that in a second but first I've
got to thank our friends over at wise
foods it's very important to be prepared
during an emergency we're seeing a lot
of political emergencies going around
recently but you want to be prepared for
natural disasters you want to be
prepared if the government can't take
care of you in an another kind of
emergency wise company takes an
innovative approach in providing
dependable simple and affordable
freeze-dried food for emergency
preparedness and outdoor use when
government resources are strained it can
be days it can be weeks it can be longer
before you can get to fresh food and
water and you can't rely on someone else
you can't rely on the government
you got to rely on yourself you don't
know what tomorrow may bring okay that
that's the point you know it's true you
hopefully you'll never have to use this
but for me just in my own peace of mind
I've got enough stresses in my life I
don't need this low level stress of what
am I going to do for sweet little ELISA
in an emergency what am I going to do
for my family don't put yourself in a
situation where you need something that
you don't have get prepared it's just
like having insurance and it's it's a
very high quality insurance and and
quite inexpensive just do it today take
care of it
you don't have to think about it again
until you do have to think about it and
you'll be glad that you have it this
week my listeners get any wise emergency
or outdoor food product at an extra 25
percent off the lowest marked price you
can get that at wise food storage comm
when you enter Knowles Canada wles at
checkout or by calling eight five five
four five three two nine four five plus
shipping is free wise has a 90 day no
questions asked return policy so there
is no risk in taking the initiative to
get yourself and your family more
prepared today wise food storage comm
promo code Knowles Canada is to get any
wise emergency right to her food product
at an extra twenty five percent off and
free shipping so is abide in a few years
ago get trying to get out ahead of this
story question is did Joe Biden actually
interfere you know Joe Biden tells a lot
of lies he tells a lot of tall tales so
did he actually do what he said that he
did New York Times seems to think so
back in May they ran the headline Biden
faces conflict of interest questions
that are being promoted by Trump and
allies so of course they have to say you
know Republicans pounced they have to
put it on Republicans but The Times felt
this was a serious enough story to run
it anyway and it's not just Ukraine so
what you got to ask yourself this is the
question when you want to find out if
this story is true or not if their legs
do it does it make sense to you that
hunter Biden got that job in Ukraine for
his expertise on energy discharge from
the Navy for blowing too much coke
hanging around downtown LA getting guns
pulled on and buying crack sleeping with
his brother's wife his late brother's
wife so his own wife leaves him getting
pinched by the cops with drugs and all
sorts of stuff in his car
that guy doesn't make sense that he got
the job no okay so why did he get the
job he obviously got the job because his
father was the vice president is that
corrupt yes was a prosecutor looking
into this sure looks like he was did Joe
Biden take extraordinary measures
threaten to withhold a ton of money in
foreign aid if that particular
prosecutor wasn't fired yeah he did do
that you got a lot of evidence here on
the side of corruption from the Biden's
and it
wasn't just Ukraine they had the same
issue in China a lot of shady business
dealings between hunter Biden and China
while Joe was vice president
so while Joe Biden but then vice
president was negotiating with the
Chinese hunter Biden's firm received a
billion dollar private equity deal with
the Chinese government this is according
to Peter Schweitzer does really good
research that private equity deal was
later increased to one and a half
billion dollars the deal came in hours
before Chinese President huge in town
met with Vice President Biden in DC for
the Nuclear Security Summit okay a lot
of smoke a lot of smoke looks like
there's some fire Joe Biden made a major
tactical error here so he was finally
confronted about this when Fox News's
Peter Doocy
came up to him it was a State Fair and
he asked Biden specifically have you
talked to your son about his foreign
business dealings Joe Biden makes a huge
error he goes on the record and says no
how many times have you ever spoken to
your son about his overseas business
dealings I've never spoken about his
overseas business I was actually on Fox
News while this was happening I thought
my segment was gonna get cut because
Biden was was making news at the time so
it goes right out of this moment they
throw it back to it was Leland Vitter
had the show at that time and he said
all right what's your reaction my first
gut reaction was if you believe that Joe
Biden never spoke to his son about his
foreign business dealings I've got a
bridge in Brooklyn to sell you there is
no way that this is credible at all that
was just what my gut told me right turns
out I was completely right because two
months ago The New Yorker reported this
is direct from The New Yorker quote as
hunter Biden recalled his father
discussed Purisima with him just once
dad said I hope you know what you're
doing and I said I do we now have it on
the record from Hunter Biden himself
that he and his father spoke about not
just his foreign business dealings but
specifically the Ukraine specifically
burries m'a so what's Joe Biden going to
do now call his son a liar and even look
at the specific context the content
rather of what he said according to
hunter Biden Joe Biden said to him I
hope you know what you're doing
meaning this deal looks a little shady
this isn't totally aboveboard what I
hope you know what you're doing why else
would he say that if the D if the deal
were totally kosher totally aboveboard
he wouldn't need to worry about that I
hope you know what you're doing means
this could be dangerous
this could compromise your career this
could compromise my career so we have
him on record as lying then he makes
another error heat he pounces on it to
use the popular term he he tries to turn
it and he tries to make a big issue out
of it and he tries to turn it on Trump
here is I know Trump deserves to be
investigated he is violating every basic
norm of a president you should be asking
him the question why is he on the phone
with a foreign leader trying to
intimidate a foreign leader if that's
what happened that appears what happened
you should be looking at Trump Trump's
doing this because knows I'll beat him
like a drum and is using the abuse of
power and every element of the
presidency to try to do something to
smear me everybody looked at this and
everybody's looked at it said there's
nothing there ask the right question
everybody's looked at it said there's
nothing there you had Politico you had
the New Yorker you had a ton of
left-wing outlets very recently saying
hunter Biden might sink Joe Biden's
chances a lot of people are looking at
it but they're not coming to the
conclusions Biden is it is bad for Biden
to put this in the news what Biden
should have done is said this is no big
deal Trump's desperate he's trying to
ease he's calling Ukraine to get them to
look into me because he knows I'm gonna
beat him it's no big deal it's old news
forget about it that's what he should
have done that would have been the Bill
Clinton approach and it used to work for
Bill Clinton a whole lot instead he
turned he made a big issue out of it go
ask from questions bad idea to go asked
from questions because then Trump is
gonna be able to use this to smush Joe
Biden as he's already beginning to do so
now there are calls for president Trump
to release the transcript of his phone
call and there's a real question about
whether or not he should do this I
actually think he should not do this not
politically I think politically it would
help him if he releases the transcript
of the Ukraine phone call but I think
it's just bad as a matter of statecraft
because you want foreign leaders to feel
as though they can speak freely when
they're talking to the president if he's
gonna just release it to the press every
time they have a phone call it really
erodes that trust I think it's a bad
idea it's bad for the office of the
president but that that aside all of
that aside president Trump says he would
be willing to do it why because he knows
this plays to his political advantage
does anybody believe that one but then
he also said long before that he did
speak to his son so he lied again but
what he said is that he wouldn't give I
think it was billions of dollars to
Ukraine unless they fired the prosecutor
who was looking at his son and his son
company the company that has done works
with and that's very dishonest thing and
I'm not looking to hurt side I'm not
even looking to hold him do it to be
honest but he said a very bad thing he
said a very foolish thing now me or the
other hand my conversation with the
president the new president of Ukraine
was perfect they put out a statement
last night they said the same thing it
was a warm friendly conversation there
was no quid pro quo
there was nothing it was a perfect
conversation classic classic Trump move
my conversation with Ukraine wasn't just
good wasn't just appropriate it was
perfect
couldn't had you never had a better
conversation okay folks is the most
beautiful conversation so he's playing
this perfectly he actually is I don't
know if the conversation was perfect but
the way he's playing this politically is
really perfect you notice he's not going
that hard after Biden he lands the punch
he says Biden lies we know he lied we
have we have him on record lying but
look I don't want to hurt Joe that bad
it's just he said a wrong thing you said
a dishonest thing Trump doesn't need to
go that hard after Biden because he can
send his his hounds to go hard after
button you can send Rudy Guiliani to go
on the sunday talk shows as he did on
Fox News this past Sunday and totally
drop the bomb
here is the bomb that very well may end
for all Joe Biden's campaign when Biden
got the prosecutor fired the new
prosecutor who Biden approved you'll get
to approve a prosecutor in a foreign
country unless something fishy is going
on the new prosecutor dropped the case
not just on Biden's kid and the crooked
company that Biden's kid worked for
barista that was done as a matter of
record in October of 2016 after the guy
got tanked he also dropped the case on
George Soros's company called an tak Ann
tag is the company where there's
documentary evidence that they were
producing false information about Trump
about Biden fusion GPS was there go back
and listen in Eleanor's testimony Nellie
Orr says that there was a lot of contact
between Democrats and the Ukraine well I
have all the contacts and John when the
rest of this comes out and we look at
China and the 1.5 billion that the that
the Biden family took out of China while
that guy was negotiating for us this
will be a lot bigger than Spiro Agnew
they have fallen into a trap he's right
they have fallen into a trap that that
is the way to say it Rudy Giuliani is
not always great on these Sunday shows
he's made a lot of missteps as as
Trump's lawyer and he's caused a lot of
headaches at times for the White House
this is Rudy Giuliani at his best I mean
this is that classic 90s Rudy Giuliani
just great prosecutor slick as can be
and he's diagnosing it correctly
all these questions that Joe Biden
doesn't want raised or have been raised
because Joe Biden handled this matter in
a stupid way a lot of the ire that's
coming up a lot of the fake ire that's
coming up about Trump on the Ukraine
call comes from the fact that Rudy
Giuliani was on the call too so what
they're saying is it wasn't the White
House Counsel that was on the call with
you it was your personal lawyer and if
it's your personal lawyer it's a
campaign matter and if it's a campaign
matter then it's illegal and if it's
illegal then okay they're drawing a
distinction without a difference so so
it's true the personal lawyer was on
here not the White House Counsel there
were also lots of government officials
on the call there were a lot of people
in the intelligence community on the
call not just in the United States but
in Ukraine too
the president is the president he's one
guy okay so his his actions don't
fundamentally change their character
based on who is sitting next to him if
the White House Counsel were sitting
next to him on the call and he asked
Ukraine multiple times to look into Joe
Biden you would be seeing the same news
story would be exactly the same thing
but it's more convenient for them
because Rudy Giuliani was sitting next
to him he was on the call too so but
then you can go after him here's what I
know the left doesn't learn anything
okay they spent three years trying to
impeach Trump for collusion and stormy
Daniels and probably for eating two
scoops of ice cream at dinner it hasn't
worked and they've spent their
credibility was Trump's call with
Ukraine appropriate I don't know I don't
know that it was maybe it wasn't
definitely I know it's not uncommon I
mean I did but it sort of skirts a-line
I mean if you've got the state if you've
got the President of the United States
using his office to specifically request
that someone look into your political
opponent that skirts a line that's
probably not totally kosher I think
everyone does it but I don't know is it
illegal I don't really see evidence that
it's illegal but you know sure it's a
little dodgy I have no idea whether it
was appropriate by the letter of the law
what I do know is Trump will face no
consequences for this the other thing I
know is that this will backfire on Joe
Biden right it's not that President
Trump is pure as the driven snow
it's that anything you can accuse Trump
of you can double eq's Biden of Trump is
dishonest you say Joe Biden is one of
the most famous Liars in American
politics he had to drum Pat it drop it
of the presidential race in 1988 because
he was lying so much he's told he's been
called out even by the left-wing press
for multiple major lies even recently
Trump is nepotistic and corrupt Joe
Biden literally threatened to withhold
American aid to Ukraine if they didn't
stop looking into his son and let him
off the hook for his corruption a lot
worse than anything Trump has been
accused of in terms of nepotism and
corruption Trump is all
you say Joe Biden is older than Donald
Trump anything you throw at Trump is
truer of Joe Biden this is Hillary 2.0 I
think Democrats are sick of it I think
they went with Hillary in 2016 because
it was her turn and probably because
they didn't want to get suicided with
two bullets in the back of the head I
don't know I'm not saying I don't know
why why would they want to do it again
why would they want Hillary again
another old crook who Democrats don't
really like that much and who very
likely would get crushed by Trump in
2020 if Biden were smart he would have
let it slide he would downplayed it but
he can't resist and I think this is very
likely the beginning of the end for him
we're seeing it in real time
the latest Des Moines Register or CNN
Mediacom Iowa poll which was just
released on Saturday night which is
actually before a lot of this blew up
shows that Warren's support among
registered Democrats is now above Joe
Biden's in Iowa
she's a 22 percent he's a 20 percent
still within the margin of error but you
see the trendline is moving for Warren
that's in Iowa first caucus if Biden
loses Iowa he's done bad news for
Democrats generally Biden is the only
candidate for black support he has any
he's the only one that has basically any
black support so the Democrats need
black support to win the general
election Joe Biden has all the black
support at least of the top-tier
candidates but he's losing Democrat
support overall which puts Democrats in
a much much tougher position very tough
week for them so let's get off of
politics let's turn to the culture Sarah
Silverman gets woke on canceled culture
good news on the border
Candace Owens kills it on Capitol Hill
and some really disturbing stuff from
the left on climate change you got to go
to Daley wire.com to get it ten bucks a
month $100 for an annual membership you
get me you get the Andrew Clavin show
you get the Ben Shapiro show you get the
Matt Walsh show you get to ask questions
in the mailbag you get another Kingdom
which we've been recording and this
season is the best one yet
you get backstage you get everything and
you get the leftist here's tumbler bunch
of climate activists and Switzerland
held a funeral for a glacier melting the
amount of water that you're gonna see
from glaciers melting is nothing
compared to the amount of water salty
delicious water that you're going to get
from all those leftist tears get that
tumblr or you're gonna drown go to daily
water calm we'll be right back with a
lot more
let's turn to the culture the Emmys were
last night didn't know about it
yeah I didn't I didn't really notice
that much either this was the lowest
rated Emmys of all time the Emmys don't
matter anymore
ratings sucked to an all-time low they
were down 23% over last year
down almost a quarter over last year at
which was last year's show was on a
Monday night compared to the last time
that the Emmys were on a Sunday night
ratings were down even worse it was 30
percent this is pretty devastating now
you might be wondering who hosted the
Emmys last night no one no one they
can't get a host of the show no one
wants to host these shows one cuz
nobody's watching it and two because the
minute you host this show canceled
culture is gonna come out and ruin your
life and ruin your career like they did
to Kevin Hart like they do to anybody
now who comes out to host these shows
and no one wants to do it no one would
accept it even Sarah Silverman who is a
left-wing comedian I mean she is a
validly leftist she was asked why there
was no host why she wouldn't take the
host and she said it's obvious cancel
culture is making it such that no one
would ever want that job they don't want
comedians to talk would you offer to
step in no nobody wants to do it either
I mean it's thankless it's a thankless
job she's right not only is a thankless
it can ruin your career when even Sarah
Silverman is coming around to a
conservative critique of the culture you
know you've gone too far and the term
canceled culture gets thrown around a
lot and people don't seem to know
exactly what it is canceled culture is
political correctness with teeth
political correctness is the speech
codes and the behavior codes that the
left has been pushing for at this point
very prominently for 30 or 40 years and
really for longer than that canceled
culture is what happens what the left
will do to you when you transgress those
speech and behavior codes so ten years
ago Kevin Hart makes some gay jokes he
gets canceled he's going to host the
Oscars they ruin his career last lab oh
just a little while ago a couple weeks
ago that a new Saturday Night Live cast
member was discovered to have made jokes
about how Chinese
people sometimes substitute the L for
the r when they're speaking English just
an obvious joke and an obvious fact that
we've all heard he made that joke a year
ago they cancelled him they got him
fired
Scarlett Johansson last year said that
actresses should be able to play people
that they are not she said she should be
allowed to play a trans woman which by
the way if trans women are real women
then why can't a woman play a trans
woman a lot of questions that are raised
there but the broader point is that
actors can play people that they are not
which is the definition of acting that's
all she said they tried to go after her
she was forced to apologize for that
that's cancel culture cancel culture
comes fundamentally from a place of
weakness you you cancel someone when you
can't refute what they're saying or when
you can't even tolerate that somebody
somewhere has a different opinion than
you do this is the the the same as PC
right the same as PC is you distort
language because you can't win an
argument using clear language so instead
of actually using clear expression what
you have to do is pervert the language
itself and that way you win from the
very beginning by setting up an
impossible situation for your opponent a
very very small group of people support
this this is the way cancel culture has
always worked cancel cultures you get a
very tiny group of activists and you get
them to to put a lot of repeated
pressure on a company or an advertiser
corporation and you pressure them to
fire whoever the person is that you
don't like and then they do it because
when you're even when you're customer
service for Pepsi if you get calls from
30 or 40 people saying cancel Michal
Knowles cancel Andrew Klavan cancel Ben
Shapiro you just do it because you think
it's a whole mob but it's not how do we
know it's not and this is how Media
Matters works or sleeping giants is
another one of these leftist
organizations that have like 30 people
working for them but they make it seem
like they have 300 million people the
way I know this this is true is because
our pals here at the Daily wire before
The Daily wire existed had a website
called truth revolt and they said look
we're gonna do to the left with the left
does to us and we're gonna show you how
bad it is so they had 30 or 40 people on
call and whenever some leftist would do
something they didn't like they would
get the 30 or 40 people to go out and
call the advertisers and boycott them
and try to get the guy fired and it
worked but it's 30 or 40 people
it's not real it's just an illusion most
people hate that I mean even you know
our pals here hated it when they were
doing it they just said that the right
shouldn't unilaterally disarm in the
face of the left so most people hate it
I think we're gonna see the same sort of
backlash on cancel culture that you saw
with political correctness the backlash
to political correctness in many ways
and pretty explicitly assured president
Trump into the White House in 2016 you
you're seeing a backlash to that you're
seeing a backlash already to cancel
culture even Sarah Silverman in many
ways it's going to be led by the
comedians because when you've got a
stifling totalitarian sort of
environment the the easiest way to crack
it to put a little [ __ ] in that armor
is to tell some jokes to make fun of it
to laugh at it that that's that's a way
that the totalitarian regimes and
totalitarian cultures cannot stand to be
laughed at they can't laugh at
themselves they can't have any sense of
humor fanatics never have any sense of
humor so that's one way we're seeing
this breakdown now meanwhile you're
getting great news on the political
front you know well you have people
screaming and hissing and talking about
how President Trump is committing
genocide because he's enforcing
immigration laws you have the majority
of Americans supporting the enforcement
of immigration laws and it's going along
pretty well
good news at the border the Department
of the Interior is transferring 560
acres of federal land to the Department
of the army which means that this land
is now going to be used to construct
another 70 miles of border wall and
they're being pretty smart about it the
land that they're using is a land that
you know doesn't have national parks on
it it doesn't have Indian tribes on it
it's a pretty wide open to be used so
while the craziness and the hysteria
could goes on and those small little
groups of canceled cultural leftists
conservatives are doing the slow and
steady work of fixing up the culture you
saw this in Los Angeles the persistence
big Trump supporter came out and a bunch
of Trump supporters led a major cleanup
that that cleaned up tons and tons
literally tons and tons of trash in LA
they're going about doing the work and
those steady results I think are going
to get a lot of a lot of appreciation
from the America
people who aren't going to get fooled by
canceled culture over on Capitol Hill
Candace Owens our pal was giving
congressional testimony she was giving
congressional testimony on what it's
like to be black in America her other
panelists who were who were going off on
her who were inveighing against her were
all white she was black it got me
thinking though about privilege it got
me thinking about white privilege you
got me thinking about the way that
racial politics play into all of this
craziness
here's Candace's excellent testimony the
audacity of you to bring up the Christ
Church shooting manifesto and make it
seem as if I laughed at people that were
slaughtered by a homicidal maniac maniac
is in my opinion absolutely despicable
and I think that we should be above that
to try to assign reality or any meaning
to a homicide homicidal maniac writing a
manifesto which by the way let the
record show also stated spyro the dragon
the child's cartoon as a source of
inspiration he also cited Nelson Mandela
as a source of information I don't think
I don't think that Nelson Mandela has
inspired mosque shootings you can
correct me if you think I'm wrong you
won't you would rather assign meaning to
a homicidal maniac than to actually
address that I said to the things that I
said today that are actually harming
black America number one father absence
number two the education system and the
illiteracy rate illegal immigration
ranks high abortion ranks high white
supremacy and white nationalism if I had
to make a list again of 100 things would
not be on it this hearing in my opinion
is a farce and it is ironic that you're
sitting here and you're having three
Caucasian people testify and tell you
what their expertise are do I know my
expertise are black in America I've been
black in America my whole life all
thirty years and I can tell you that you
guys have done the exact same thing
every four years ahead of an election
cycle and it needs to stop absolutely
devastating devastating stuff the Left
overplayed their hand okay the left has
always done very well on racial politics
at least for the last 60 70 years
they've done very well on racial
politics not because of the facts I mean
it's pretty amazing that the Democratic
Party which is the party of slavery the
party of the Ku Klux Klan
the party of Jim Crow the party that
opposed civil rights that that party the
party that even if you don't want to
assign malice to the welfare state
through their welfare state programs has
destroyed the black family and and set
black Americans back 50 60 years that
party always did very well that movement
that leftist movement always did very
well on racial politics because it was
all innuendo so as all those Republicans
are racist they don't like you those
conservatives they don't like you forget
about our policies forget about the
effect of what we do on black America
just they look they don't like you we
like you so hey we're good right
and it worked it's worked pretty well if
they just kept up the innuendo you I
think it would continue to work for them
if they just kept up the innuendo Trump
is corrupt Trump is colluding with
Russia
now he's colluding with the Ukraine even
though Russia and the Ukraine don't like
each other but somehow he was colluding
with both of them Trump is doing this
Trump is doing that if they just kept it
at the innuendo it would work but they
don't they have to go too far they have
to overplay their hand you know I think
if you asked people is there white
privilege is there certain privilege to
being white in America
yeah probably there is here's a good
example Candice touched on it black
people in America are three times as
likely to be killed by abortion as white
people are there are more black babies
killed before they're born in New York
City then are born that is that is a
white privilege based on your skin color
you are more likely to survive birth and
by the way that's not just a cultural
matter that is a political matter mostly
white people in government are pushing
those policies mostly white liberal
activists are encouraging black mothers
to murder their babies and black mostly
white people in government are forcing
you and I to subsidize that with our
taxes that's that's a pretty sick white
privilege and but it is a white
privilege and it's a very important one
now look everybody gets privileges I
mean there's a black and Hispanic
privilege when you apply for college
admissions this has been codified
through a policy called firm
of action affirmative action is race
discrimination it helps people who are
black and Hispanic and Native American
and other races it hurts people who are
white and Asian there's a major lawsuit
now against Harvard because of
discrimination against Asians you can
argue all you want and say the policy is
good we need this racial discrimination
because we need to address past
injustice 'as a fair conversation to
have but the policy itself is race
discrimination without race
discrimination there is no policy so I
guess you could call that a black
privilege or a Hispanic privilege you
can get down to a lot of different
privileges not just based on your race
but based on your sex based on your
where you're born based on whether you
had two parents growing up we all have
the privilege of life we didn't earn our
life we we are not responsible for
creating our life life is a gift that
was given to us we have a responsibility
to be stewards of our life that life
will be taken away from us at the end
probably without very much consent as
what usually happens we all have
wonderful privileges that we should be
grateful for you don't even need to deny
them we also all have suffering I could
go through a list of tough things that
happened in life really raw breaks that
you don't want to get you don't know
somebody's suffering and and their
suffering isn't based on their race
usually it's not based on their race at
all it's based on their circumstances
their personal circumstances everybody
has those things you could have a mature
conversation about that and I think
ultimately what that would lead to is a
society of gratitude when we count our
blessings which far outnumber our
sufferings even though the rain falls on
the just and the unjust alike and falls
on the rich and the poor alike and the
black and the white alike and everybody
else our blessings outweigh our
sufferings that's good that would be a
good conversation to have but left can't
have that conversation one because it
would take away the racial grievance
which is at the heart of so much of
their their identity politics Candis
Owens totally smacking that down really
brilliantly and it also got me thinking
about the climate issue you have there's
this poor girl a Greta Thunder who's a
sixteen-year-old autistic girl from
Sweden and
left has pimped her out and made her the
spokesman for climate change it's kind
of funny they say climate change is the
scientific movement and yet the leader
of the movement is a sixteen year old
girl from Sweden and their policy is the
most prominent one now with those
plastic straws is based not on a
scientific study but on the homework
assignment of a nine-year-old boy named
Milo cress that's where the straw thing
comes from is a homework assignment from
a fourth grade boy not a scientific
study so I don't see a whole lot of
science there they had a big Climate
Change hullabaloo weekend or and and
they had all of these different what we
would call religious rituals they had
climate confessionals on NBC
they had climate services they had a
funeral for a glacier I don't know what
that looks like
they had climate anxiety support groups
which is more or less a secular church
service but what they did to this girl
is really awful it's really awful and
it's going to prompt a backlash because
yet again they are over playing their
hand this is this girl greta thunderbird
was just speaking to the UN and she's
highly emotional she's highly since
aureus she's obviously not speaking from
any scientific expertise she's a 16 year
old girl here's what she had to say this
is all wrong I shouldn't be up here I
should be back in school on the other
side of the ocean
yet you all come to us young people for
hope how dare you you have stolen my
dreams in my childhood with your empty
words yet I'm one of the lucky ones
people are suffering people are dying
entire ecosystems are collapsing we are
in the beginning of a mass extinction
and all you can talk about is money
and fairy tales of eternal economic
growth how dare you
performance not that great but it goes
too far it goes too far and people look
at this and I think they say you know
left you've you've gone too far with
what the left has done is encouraged a
16 year old mentally ill girl to drop
out of school sporadically to help them
sell socialism I say she's mentally ill
because she has autism she's autistic
and her parents and the international
left
I said International lectures at the UN
are totally taking advantage of this
girl who has a mental illness they are
they are whipping her up into a frenzy
and making her think she's going to die
they make this girl think I mean this
girl has all the advantages in the world
and she says that we've all stolen her
dreams from her as she's giving a speech
at the UN whatever that means it's easy
to make fun of her it's easy to say she
should go to timeout or something or be
grounded for for this kind of stuff let
her calm down maybe get her a
psychologist and a nap or something but
it's not her fault she's a mentally ill
teenager it's her parents and it's the
left broadly they were doing this that
is so egregious that is so wicked to do
that to somebody everybody knows that
everybody sees that it's over playing
the hand I mean they had already
overplayed their hand on the climate if
you just said to people hey the climates
really getting bad so oh what's
happening to the climate oh it's cooling
down that's what they said in the 70s
the climates cooling and that's really
bad so we got a you know you've got to
give us socialism I bet a lot of people
would have gone along with it then even
in the 90s when they said yeah the
climate is really really bad it's what's
wrong with the climate oh it's heating
up seems like a good thing because it
was just cooling down and now it's
heating up so problem solved right no no
no it's actually bad
it's bet we used to want it to heat up
but now we want it to cool down so it's
bad you got to give us socialism I think
a lot of people would have going along
with that then you had Al Gore make his
movie say look global look we're
scientists okay global warming it's
gonna or whatever it is now climate
change it's gonna kill us you got to
give us socialism and people said wait I
thought was the scientists why
the Al Gore Al Gore's no scientist said
no well yeah ok never mind even then I
think they would have gone along with it
but now you have climate confessionals
religious rituals the sale of
indulgences in carbon tax credits and
you make the face of this movement an
autistic teenager who you're pulling out
of school depriving her of an education
whipping her up into an emotional frenzy
ruining her life it's too far you've
gone too far you've overplayed your hand
which they always do
good news for conservatives good news
for the culture bad news for the victims
of the left it always is
that's our show come back tomorrow we
got a lot more in the meantime I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael Nolt
show see them
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boy
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel y
douse key edited by danny D'Amico audio
is mixed by Mike gore Amina hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera and our
production assistant is NIC Sheehan the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19 on
the Matt Walsh oh we're not just
discussing politics we're talking
culture faith family all of the things
that are really important to you so come
join the conversation